someone's getting a little anxious for
their due date the blessings are
literally knocking me out at this point
little nausea keeps having fun with his
baby bump on social media and it's all
in the name of his forthcoming debut
album montero which is set to drop on
september 17th
[Music]
and this gift is just one of the hijinks
on social media the rapper tweeted this
image writing oh my god i'm trying not
to cry thank you for the early baby
shower gift barack obama
in all likelihood this gift did not come
from obama but it does remind us of the
last time little nas ex name checked the
44th president
[Music]
following the release of obama's summer
playlist in 2019
little nausea celebrated old town road
making the cut by sharing this
photoshopped pic featuring obama's head
placed on little na's ex's body he
simply tweeted obama said and on tick
tock little nausea asked all of his fans
what they're bringing to the baby shower
[Music]
[Applause]
he also shared another behind the scenes
peak of his photo shoot this time
documenting getting tested for kova 19
on set making sure i don't have kobet
last week the musician shared a full-on
maternity shoe to celebrate his baby
sporting a prosthetic bump flower crown
and even posted a sonogram he also
tick-tocked this reveal
[Music]
[Applause]
explained the idea was born no pun
intended out of a conversation he had
with a stylist
quote she was like wow this all comes
together your album your baby i was like
yeah this is my baby huh as a joke she
was like yeah you should do a pregnancy
shoe
it's amazing
and these latest posts come just days
after he kind of trolled fellow rapper
drake's latest album launch
after drake shared the cover art for
certified lover boy a series of emojis
depicting pregnant women the comic by
your name singer posted this mimified
version featuring pregnant men i'm just
like extremely thankful and happy now
this whole pregnancy thing doesn't stop
there because on thursday little nauseas
tweeted to his followers
let me get offline all of the negative
energy is not good for the baby
[Music]